وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد الشاب
الفلسطيني الذي اصيب في وقت سابقا اليوم
برصاصي برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الذي اطلق عليه من المسافه صفر في حواره
جنوبيه نابلس نشر ناشطون صورا قالوا انها
لفلسطينيين اثنين حوالات تخليص الشاب من
قبضه الجندي الذي اطبق الخناقه عليه وسحبه
الى مكان اخر واطلق النار عليه وقال سعود
عيان ان القوات الاحتلال منع الطلاق قيمه
الاسعاف من الوصول الى الشاب بعد اصابته
وزعمت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الشابه
حاول سرقه سلاح الجندي وطعنه ليقوم الجندي
باطلاق النار عليه
معنا من رب بلغ مراسل الجزيره سمير ابو
شماله سمير ليست المره الاولى التي توثق
فيها الكاميرات اطلاقه نار واعداما
ميدانيا من المسافه صفر على شاب فلسطيني
وفي المره الاولى لم يحدث شيء لم يعاقب من
فعل ذلك
نعم بقول تاكيد زين العابدين هذه روايات
اسرائيليه دائما تكون جاهزه لعمليات سواء
تضرع بعمليات طعن او داهس او غير ذلك في
عديد المرات في حوادث متفرقه في الضفه
الغربيه ولكن في هذه الحادثه الكاميرا كان
توثق بشكل مباشر بان الجندي الاسرائيلي
اطلق النار على هذا الشاب الفلسطيني من
مسافه صفر
وقد اعدمه بدم بارد حسب كل الروايات
الفلسطينيه وايضا التصريحات الفلسطيني
التي خرجت عقبها هذا الحادث الذي كشفته
الكاميرا وهذه الصوره بان الجنديه
الايطالي كان بامكانه ان كان قد تعرض
للخطر حسب الروايه الايصاليه
ان يحيده باطلاق النار على ساقيه ويحاول
عرقله ااا وجوده في المكان ولكن كان هناك
يبدو
تعليمات باطلاق النار لقتل الفلسطينيين في
هذه المشهد الذي بدنا نراها بشكل يومي في
المناطق المتفرقه في الضفه الغربيه حسب
روايه شهود العيان في هذه حادثه يتحدثون
بان كان هناك حادث سير قد وقع بين هذا
الشاب واحد سيارات المستوطنين وزوجته كان
مشاده كلاميه بين المستوطن والشاب
الفلسطيني الذي ايضا تعرض لهذه
الضرب من المستوطنه الاسرائيلي وحين اتدخل
الجندي الاسرائيلي وقد قرر باعتقال هذا
الشاب ولكن كان هناك همم الفيديو قد الذي
نشراه صحفيون ومواطنون قد وثق بان اثنين
من المواطنين حاولان ايه افلات هذا الشاب
من قبضه الجندي ولكن سحبه الى مكان اخر
الشاب نفسه حاول التملص من هذا الجندي
الايطالي ولكن الجندي على ما يبدو انه قد
شعر بانه تعرض للخطر حسب روايته بكل تاكيد
في كل مره نسمع بها من الجندي يتعرض لهذه
الخطا واطلق الرصاص عليه بالمشدته من
المسدسه من مسافه صفر وقتله في المكان
الجيش حتى الجيش لم
يسمح لي الطواقب الاسعاف الفلسطينيه التي
وصلت على الفور الى المكان في بلده حواره
في نابلس من الوصول اليه لانقاذه وتقديم
المساعده لهذا الشاب المصاب ولكن همم تم
منع هذه الطواقي من الاسعاف
استشهد هذا الشاب البالغ من العمر 22 عاما
وهو شاب عمار مثل حسب مصادر الطبيه
الفلسطينيه من قريه اوصرين قضاء نابلس همم
الجيش الاسرائيلي قد دفع بقوات اضافيه الى
بلده حوار ايضا كان هناك مواجهات مع
المواطنين من ادى الى اصابته منهم بالرصاص
المطاطي والاختراق بالغاز المدمن حسب
التوقف الطبيه من جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني عبد زين العابدين
وزاره الخارجيه وجميع الفصل الفلسطيني قد
دانت هذه الجريمه واعتبرتها هي جريمه
اعدام بدمن بارد وحمله الحكومه
الاسرائيليه عن تداعيات هذه الاعتداءات
وهذه الجرائم المستمره بحق الفلسطينيين
سمير ابو شمله من رام الله